there's a political consultant who went on
MSNBC and said, if you were supporting Bernie
Sanders over Elizabeth Warren, given everything
that we know today, you are sexist.
I wish that this was a fake headline.
It is not.
Let's look at the video of Emily Tish Sussman
saying this in her own words doing the thing
where she says, some people are saying if
you support Bernie over Warren, it's sexist
and I think there might be something to it.
Take a look.
There's, there's a ceiling, there is nowhere
to go but there is no up to go.
And all of those.
I actually heard overheard someone saying
that I thought was an interesting point that
basically at this point if you are still supporting
Sanders as opposed to Warren, it's kind of
showing your sexism because she has more detailed
plans and her plans have evolved.
I thought that was an interesting point and
I think there may be something to it.
Yeah, I agree with all that.
Uh, what there are about three, there's at
least three layers through which we need to
analyze this.
Three lenses through, which we need to try
to understand this.
First of all is just the sheer stupidity of
this comment.
If you have two candidates and one is male
and another is female, if supporting the male
is a sign of sexism against the female candidate,
then by extrapolation from that, if you have
a Jewish candidate and a Christian candidate
and you support the Christian candidate, Elizabeth
Warren in this case, that must be antisemitism
against the Jewish candidate Bernie Sanders,
right?
No, I would be an idiot if I tried to make
that argument.
I would immediately lose all credibility to
put forth any kind of political analysis,
which is why I'm not going to make such a
stupid argument.
And that's equally dumb as what, uh, Emily
Tish system assessments says here, uh, that's
the argument that's being made.
And I hesitate to even use the term argument
because it's not really an argument.
It's just nonsense.
So that's problem number one.
The argument is idiotic.
Secondly, we have here the growing problem
that I've been telling you about.
Last week I did a segment where I said the
critiques from left to left, the critiques
among democratic primary voters of other democratic
candidates are starting to get to be the level
of toxicity, uh, that is going to hurt the
eventual nominee and helped Donald Trump in
2020.
Okay.
These are the types of more vicious and inaccurate
attacks that are going to self-destruct and
lead to the reelection of Donald Trump.
And there are all sorts of reasons why someone
might support Bernie Sanders over Elizabeth
Warren and there are reasons people are supporting
Elizabeth Warren over Bernie Sanders, none
of which have to do with religion or gender.
Bernie, for example, has been clear that Medicare
for all is the path forward for healthcare.
Now you can agree or disagree with that.
That's his position.
Elizabeth Warren has been more wishy washy.
Now you might agree with Warren.
There are reasonable people who can say, you
know, I don't want to put all my eggs in the
Medicare for all basket.
And so I like Elizabeth Warren's more open
minded approach or you could say, I don't
see Elizabeth Warren is open-minded.
Uh, I see her merely as wishy-washy and then
willing to take a position.
I'm going with Bernie on this issue.
None of that has to do with religion.
None of that has to do with gender.
Warren voted for a bigger Pentagon budget.
Bernie voted against it.
That might be a reason to vote for Bernie
has nothing to do with sexism.
Obviously Bernie won't take corporate PAC
money in the general and Elizabeth Warren
will.
There's a big argument to be had about that.
On the one hand, do you want someone who is
potentially going to be at a disadvantage
merely because they're saying, I won't take
PAC money and my opponent will and that hurts
me.
Or you could say, I love that Bernie is not
going to compromise principles and he is not
going to take corporate pack money in the
general whatever.
Right.
I'm just telling you what the arguments are
to say that supporting the male candidate,
because as Emily Sussman said, Warren's plans
are more detailed, supposedly is absurd and
pathetic.
It's, it actually is.
It's so sad that this is what things have
come to.
These are ridiculous attacks that are baseless
at their core, but they're destructive to
the movement.
There are serious critiques and disagreements
anyone can have with Bernie or with Warren,
but this is absurd, childish and counter productive.
Now the other thing, layer three as we might
call it, is that this particular consultant
or pundit or whatever, Emily Tish Sussman,
she is part of the democratic establishment
that has shown that they don't like Bernie.
She's the former vice president of campaigns
for the center for American progress, an establishment
democratic outfit.
Her father, Donald Sussman, was one of the
top Hillary donors in 2016 donating more than
$22 million to Hillary.
So I think you probably understand what's
going on here.
This is truly terrible stuff.
You hate to see it.
If what you care about is removing Donald
Trump in 2020 and unfortunately more and more
Democrats are doing it.
I'm not saying everybody's the same.
Not every candidate has this going on to the
same degree, but we've seen enclaves of toxic
Bernie supporters.
We've seen toxic enclaves of Bernie detractors.
We've seen Biden supporters who were doing
right wing talking points about socialism
and communism, about Bernie and Warren.
We've seen anti Biden, people that are going
well beyond what the evidence tells us should
be the case against Biden into what are smears.
We've seen Warren detractors, we've seen the
cult of personality around Tulsi support around
Tulsi Gabard with some of our supporters,
yang supporters.
I've been, some of them have been going over
the line.
This is getting bad.
This is exactly how we lose and I hope, I
mean, what else can I say?
I hope that everybody realizes this and abandons
this a strategy.